le bruit des bottes résonne de plus en
plus fort à la frontière entre la russie
et l'ukraine cette ligne qui pourraient
être franchis par les troupes de
vladimir poutine à n'importe quel moment
oui nous craignons un conflit armé en
ukraine nous sommes extrêmement
préoccupés par le positionnement du
gouvernement russe qui évolue lui le
canada qui a dépêché plus tôt cette
semaine la ministre des affaires
étrangères à kiev ne cesse de réitérer
son soutien à l'ue craint nous allons
continuer d'être là en tant qu'allié les
partenaires de l'ukraine mais au delà
des 200 soldats canadiens qui entraîne
des troubles sur place il faut dit yeves
des armes équipements militaires pour
l'instant juste être 12 refuse de
s'avancer
excuses horizons rappelant qu'un envoi
du genre pourraient davantage provoqué
la russie les états-unis ou n'hésite pas
à promettre plus d'équipements à
l'ukraine pour l'aider à se défendre
surtout explique le secrétaire d'état en
visite à kiev
si la russie bat bel et bien de l'avant
et qu'une incursion
mais si les conservateurs critiquent la
mollesse du gouvernement trudeau
d'autres doutent que la solution passe
par l'envoi d'armes je pense pas que ça
fasse frissonner
les russes dans leurs bottes que de
savoir que les normes canadiennes
seraient bande vu m le canada doit
mettre l'accent sur la diplomatie croit
cet expert il faut tenter de voir qu'est
ce que l'ukraine est prête à céder aux
russes pour empêcher une incursion
militaire très probable ce sont eux et
c'est là où certains experts pensent que
le canada pourrait jouer un rôle plus
actif étant donné ses liens historiques
avec l'ukraine mais il reste que dans
les négociations avec moscou le poids
lourd deux morts washington
une rencontre au sommet d'ailleurs
prévue vendredi à genève entre le
secrétaire d'état américain et son
homologue russe et si laurent certains
radio canada ottawa